.
Der Bundesrat hat heute entschieden,
die Situation als
ausserordentliche Lage zu erklären.
(Alain Berset) ... fermé les écoles,
nous avons limité la vie sociale ...
(Simonetta Sommaruga)
Die Einschränkungen
werden viele Unternehmen,
unzählige Betriebe,
Angestellte und Freischaffende
hart treffen.
(Alain Berset) Bleiben Sie zu Hause.
(Simonetta Sommaruga)
Die Regelung gilt ab Mitternacht
und dauert vorerst
bis zum 19. April.
So kurzfristig, um 17 Uhr,
das ist wirklich schlimm.
Ja.
Schock.
Es ist sehr surreal.
Man erwartet nicht,
so etwas mitzuerleben. - Nein.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Ich lache,
weil ich auch nicht weinen kann.
Ich habe keine Zeit,
um nachzudenken und zu weinen.
Aber ich denke darüber nach,
wie es weitergeht.
Riech mal! Wie lecker.
Was machen wir damit?
5 kg Mortadella.
Wir hacken ihn
und machen damit Tortelloni.
Parmaschinken - 24 Monate gereift.
42 Fr. pro kg - schade.
Tortelloni.
Es ist wie eine Wolke -
wir wissen nicht,
was mit uns passiert.
Monsieur Berset,
haben Sie eine Alternative?
Schränken Sie doch nicht
unser ganzes Leben ein!
Es fühlt sich an, wie Goodbye
zu sagen, einfach Tschüss zu sagen.
* "Time to Say Goodbye" von
Andrea Bocelli und Sarah Brightman *
# Time to say goodbye ...
Alain Berset ...
- Merci vielmals!
... ich habe dir
auf Twitter geschrieben.
Schreib mir zurück.
- Hör auf!
* "Time to Say Goodbye" von
Andrea Bocelli und Sarah Brightman *
# Adesso
sì, li vivrò, con te partirò.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
# Su navi per mari che, io lo so ...
# no, no, non esistono più ...
(Daniel Koch) Die Zahlen
sind weiter angestiegen.
Sie werden auch die nächsten Tage
weiter ansteigen.
Universitätsspital Zürich USZ.
In Rekordtempo
werden Kapazitäten aufgebaut.
Es ist jetzt geplant,
im Aufwachraum die Intensiv-
kapazitäten des USZ zu erweitern.
Deshalb verschiebe ich die
Beatmungsgeräte in den Aufwachraum.
D.h.: einmal abbauen
und drüben wieder aufbauen.
Bilder,
gefilmt von Oberarzt Lukas Kandler.
Er dreht für SRF in der COVID-19-
Abteilung des Universitätsspitals.
Aus Sicherheitsgründen
sind Medien nicht zugelassen.
Unter normalen Bedingungen wäre ich
jetzt dort als Oberarzt tätig.
Aufgrund der Corona-Situation
ist ein privates
Dokumentarfilmprojekt gescheitert
bzw. wurde es zumindest
auf später verschoben.
Deshalb sind wir überein gekommen,
dass ich im Spital filme,
im Spital einen Dokumentarfilm drehe
über die Bewältigung der
Corona-Situation, der Corona-Krise
und was die Mitarbeiter
alles auf die Beine stellen.
Vor knapp zwei Wochen
waren diese Räume leer, leergeräumt,
nichts mehr war drin,
keine Schraube, nichts.
Es war eine Riesenleistung
von allen Bereichen,
aus der Logistik,
der Administration, der Technik,
diese Räume
schnell wieder einzurichten.
Es wurde Tag und Nacht gearbeitet,
alle haben an einem Strick gezogen.
Nach einer Woche Vorbereitung
wird es jetzt ernst.
Es wird sich jetzt herausstellen,
wie gut wir vorbereitet sind
und was wir alles
noch nicht berücksichtigt haben.
Was bereitet am meisten Sorgen?
Dass ich etwas ganz Wichtiges
vergessen habe,
was jetzt in den Ablauf gehört
und in einer Situation, in der
es nicht vergessen werden sollte,
vergessen wurde.
Wir warten auf die Welle.
Am Horizont sieht man den Tsunami.
Wir wissen aber nicht,
wann und wie er uns treffen wird.
Die Intensivstation kann innerhalb
weniger Stunden eröffnet werden.
Ich nehme an,
dass sie diese Woche eröffnet wird.
* Ruhige, blubbernde Klänge *
Eine Mobilmachung dieses Ausmasses
hat es seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
nicht mehr gegeben.
Soldaten des Spitalbataillons 66 -
aufgeboten per SMS.
Es ist ein mulmiges Gefühl:
Was passiert, wie geht es weiter,
werden wir auch angesteckt?
Es herrscht Ungewissheit,
wie es jetzt weitergeht.
Erst muss man begreifen,
um was es wirklich geht.
Man hatte etwas wenig Zeit.
Aber das kommt noch.
Ich fühle mich geehrt,
dass ich einrücken darf.
* Dynamische Marschmusik *
Rund 5'000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten
sind mobilisiert.
Spitalkompanien 1 und 2 - Achtung!
Ruhen, Helm ab!
Als Ihr Kommandant
bin ich stolz auf Sie.
Jeder von Ihnen
hat vielleicht Ängste:
"Was passiert mit mir?"
"Wie geht es weiter?
Wie lange dauert die Situation an?"
Aber seien wir mutig
und leisten wir das,
was von uns verlangt wird.
* Dynamische Marschmusik *
Mit der Übernahme der Fahne,
unserer Fahne,
zeigen wir heute symbolisch
unsere Einsatzbereitschaft.
Den Feind, den es zu bekämpfen gilt,
kann man nicht sehen.
Und er könnte trotzdem überall sein.
Nun ist es an der Zeit,
das Trainierte
in die Tat umzusetzen.
Schön langsam, schön langsam.
Jetzt hält er, oder?
Ganz runter.
Es ist vorgesehen,
dass wir uns für jede Infrastruktur
bereithalten müssen.
Es werden Gesuche gestellt,
die schweizweit
durch eine zentrale Stelle
beurteilt werden.
Dort wird entschieden,
wer uns braucht.
Wir werden versuchen,
bestmöglich zu helfen.
* Abwartende Klänge *
Guten Tag, hier ist Meta Hiltebrand
vom Restaurant Le Chef in Zürich.
Sie haben online einen Tisch
für den 24. April reserviert.
Ich wollte die Reservation
bestätigen, weiss aber nicht,
ob wir am 24. April
wieder offen haben.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Tag
und bleiben Sie gesund.
Danke vielmals. Ade, merci.
Auch wenn der Betrieb gerade zu ist:
der Tiefkühler
und das Kühlhaus laufen.
Wir haben abgestellt,
was wir konnten.
Aber wir brauchen weiterhin Geld.
Jeder Tag, an dem wir zu haben,
kostet.- Wie viel?
Ich kann keine genauen Zahlen
nennen, was fehlt.
Aber wir müssen im Le Chef jeden
Monat 80'000 Fr. erwirtschaften,
um Lohnkosten, Mietkosten usw.
abdecken zu können.
Wir fressen nun unsere Reserven auf,
die wir für den Sommer hatten.
Das ist abgesagt.
Um 15.55 Uhr gibt es etwas.
Wir würden schieben.
- Es ist in Ihrer Verantwortung.
Die Emirates fliegt im Moment noch.
Ich muss schauen, was ich
im Homeoffice dringend brauche.
Zudem sind Sie
bei der AXA versichert.
... in Ihrem Fall dort
eine gute Lösung gefunden,
eigentlich für den
Kambodscha-Singapur-Teil.
Oh ja, stimmt.
Ich möchte die Quarantäne
auf den Malediven verbringen.
Evtl. buchen wir um,
aber im Moment warten wir ab.
Die ganzen Geschichten
wegen der Kurzarbeit
sind hier ebenfalls vorbereitet.
Was heisst,
in Madrid läuft nichts mehr?
Ist denn der Flug jetzt ...
der Flug ...
Wir sind jetzt in der Abklärung,
Frau Schädler.
Wie geben Ihnen Bescheid,
sobald wir eine Lösung haben.
Wir schauen, dass wir
Ihren Mann nach Hause bringen.
Ich melde mich,
sobald ich eine Lösung habe.
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
- Ja. Die Maschine ist weg.
Das Problem ist:
In Madrid geht gar nichts mehr.
Also auch kein Taxi, nichts mehr.
Aber er kann nicht einreisen
in Spanien, oder?- Nein.
Er sitzt im Transit.
Gib ihm die Nummer der Botschaft.
In Madrid?
- Ich denke, ja.
In diesem Fall ist es jetzt
wirklich, wirklich schwierig,
von hier aus irgendetwas zu machen.
Er soll sich einmal
bei der Botschaft in Madrid melden.
Wir müssen sie teilweise über ver-
schiedene Flughäfen zurückbringen,
weil es keine Direktflüge mehr gibt.
Wir wissen nicht, wie es in einem
bestimmten Land gehandhabt wird,
ob sie dann wirklich weiterkommen.
Und das sind Dinge, die einen -
wie soll ich sagen? -
sehr aufreiben.
Wir sind alle recht ...
Wir sind richtig angespannt.
Das ist so.
Wir sind
die wahrscheinlich einzige Branche,
die im Moment arbeitet
und dabei noch Geld verliert.
Es ist wirklich dramatisch.
Wir müssten jetzt die Kurzarbeit
sofort umsetzten können,
um unsere Personalkosten
herunterzufahren.
Aber daran ist jetzt
schlichtweg nicht zu denken.
Solange wir quasi auch
die Arbeit für den Bund erledigen
und versuchen, die Schweizer/-innen
oder unsere Kunden
nach Hause zu holen, können wir
unseren Betrieb nicht runterfahren.
Wie lange haben die Häschen noch?
- Schau mal nach.
Ihr müsst jetzt kurz zurück,
denn das Brot muss aufs Gitter.
So, Social Distancing.
Gastrounternehmerin Meta Hiltebrand
ist jetzt zu Hause -
mit 75 kg Mehl aus dem Restaurant.
Ich rief Basti an:
"Du, Basti, wir wohnen zusammen."
"Am besten verbringen wir
die Quarantäne gemeinsam."
Die Bedingung aber war,
dass wir niemanden treffen,
damit wir wissen,
wo wir gewesen sind.
Basti sagte Ja und meinte:
"Doch, das machen wir."
Dann haben wir am ersten Abend
Monopoly gespielt und uns gefragt,
wie wir
mit so einer Situation umgehen.
Und schon
war das Backprojekt entstanden.
Eigentlich eine
sehr witzige Entstehungsgeschichte.
Wir sind gut gelaunt, lachen, auch
wenn es überhaupt nicht lustig ist.
Aber man muss auch
das Beste daraus machen.
Darum machen wir jetzt Brot,
und das in grossen Mengen,
verschenken es den Leuten,
machen ihnen eine Freude,
ohne ein Business daraus zu machen.
"Entspannt euch, freut euch
über die kleinen Dingen im Leben,
geniesst eure Partner und hört auf,
dauernd an Geld zu denken."
Wir haben alle
noch so viele unbeantwortete Fragen.
Wir sollten einfach mal eine Woche
warten, dann wissen wir alle mehr.
Es ist völlig klar:
Der Bundesrat hat von zahlreichen
berührenden Schicksalen gehört
und gelesen.
Wir arbeiten Tag und Nacht,
um zu helfen.
(Simonetta Sommaruga)
Was wir der ganzen Bevölkerung
aber auch sagen,
und eindringlich sagen:
Wir lassen euch nicht allein,
wir kümmern uns um euch.
Am Montag, als es hiess,
wir machen zu, fragte ich mich:
"Was soll ich machen?"
"Wohin gehen denn die 10 Mrd.,
die der Bund, der Staat
zur Verfügung stellt?"
Es herrschte Ungewissheit.
Dann probiert man anzurufen,
etwas zu unternehmen.
Doch man erreicht niemanden.
Man wird
am Telefon fast angeschrien,
weil alle mit der Situation
überfordert sind.
Die selbstständige Coiffeuse
zahlt allein für ihre Wohnung
und ihren Laden
mehr als 2'000 Fr. Monatsmiete.
Wie bezahlen Sie das?
Gar nicht.
Ich kann es wirklich nicht bezahlen.
Ich habe jetzt auf dem Konto
vielleicht 1'000 Fr.
Ich kann mir überlegen:
"Bezahle ich die Miete,
bezahle ich die Versicherung?"
"Was kann ich sonst noch bezahlen?"
Ich müsste allen anrufen und sagen:
"Sorry, es tut mir leid.
Ich kann nicht bezahlen."
"Ich wäre gewillt zu bezahlen,
aber ich kann nicht."
Das ist auch ein Punkt,
der einen nicht schlafen lässt.
* Ruhige, melancholische Klänge *
Am Dienstag
war ich sehr, sehr traurig.
Ich wusste nicht,
ob ich weinen oder lachen soll.
Solange die Schliessung nicht
feststeht, kann ich nicht weinen.
Daniel Koch
ist Gast in der "Arena"-Sendung.
Mein Job ...
Das ist eine gute Frage:
"Was ist mein Job?"
Mein Job ist, zu schauen,
dass wir mit dem Coronavirus
möglichst gut über die Runde kommen.
Stellen Sie sich die Bevölkerung
wie ein einziger Patient vor.
Mein Job ist, zu schauen,
dass der Patient mit Infektion ...
Dass dieser Infektionsherd
nicht generalisiert,
möglichst unter Kontrolle
gebracht werden kann,
und die Person
am Schluss gesund wird.
Ich schaue mir noch
ein paar Mails an von Leuten,
bei denen ich weiss,
dass es wichtig sein könnte.
Könnte?
- Könnte.
Die Verantwortung
liegt nie nur bei mir.
Wenn etwas wirklich wichtig ist,
kriege ich eh eine SMS.
Jetzt muss ich kurz anrufen.
Bitte stellt den Ton ab.
Eigentlich wäre Daniel Koch in
ein paar Tagen in Pension gegangen.
Das ist mein Alltag,
den ich mir zum Schluss meiner
Karriere nicht so gewünscht habe.
Aber das ist jetzt so.
Ich denke, es wäre falsch, wenn
ich jetzt total ausflippen würde.
Aber innerlich sieht es nicht so aus,
wie Sie gegen aussen wirken.
Doch, ich bin ruhig.
Das kann ich Ihnen beweisen.
58 im Moment.
- 58?
Wie kommt das?
Betreiben Sie Triathlon?
Nein, Sport mit einem Hund.
Ein schneller Hund,
oder hat er Ausdauer?
Nein, er ist schnell.
Sie joggen mit dem Hund?
- Ja.
Sehr oft?
- Ja, wenn es die Zeit erlaubt.
In den letzten Tagen
natürlich nicht.
Diese Woche musste ich ihn in den
Hundehort geben, es ging nicht mehr.
Dort werde ich ihn abholen -
und am Sonntag gehen wir trainieren.
... Maske. Entschuldigung.
Ja, ich komme.
Wir gehen in die Maske.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Regionalspital Affoltern am Albis.
Besucherstopp auch hier -
wegen Corona.
Arzt Markus Minder auf Visite
beim schwer krebskranken
Konrad Osterwalder.
Guten Morgen.
Er leidet besonders
unter der Isolierung.
Moment, ich muss noch kurz ...
Das höchste der Gefühle ist,
wenn ich auf den Balkon gehe
und sie unten im Garten stehen.
So können wir kommunizieren.
Ich bin vor 14 Tagen
Grossvater geworden
und habe dieses Kind
nur einmal kurz gesehen.
Von Weitem -
mehr war nicht möglich.
Ich muss auch abwarten,
bis diese Zeit vorbei ist.
Erst dann ist es möglich, Zeit
mit dem Grosskind zu verbringen.
Ist es ein grosser Wunsch von Ihnen,
das Kind mal zu sehen?
Sicher, ja.
Das schauen wir
dann in Ruhe nochmals an.
Auch COVID-19-Patienten
sind hier hospitalisiert.
Das Regionalspital,
vor wenigen Wochen von manchen
noch als überflüssig erachtet,
ist jetzt wieder wichtig.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Ja ...
Im Moment um einiges besser
als zuvor.
Mich hat ein Virus erwischt,
das sehr unangenehm ist.
Ich leide an Appetitlosigkeit.
Ich kann nichts mehr essen,
nichts mehr.
Es geht nicht.
Macht es Angst?
Wenn man der Medizin vertraut,
hat man keine Angst.
Respekt hat man immer, das ist klar.
Aber Angst nicht.
Ich glaube,
unsere Medizin hat das ...
Meine Krankheit
in der momentanen Ausprägung
hat die Medizin im Griff.
Harry Gyr ist mittlerweile
wieder gesund zu Hause.
Weggis, 6 Uhr morgens.
Adrian Steiner,
Geschäftsführer der Firma Thermoplan.
Herr Steiner, wie geht's Ihnen?
Gut. Es ist Montagmorgen.
Es war ein turbulentes Wochenende.
Die Neuigkeiten zum Thema Corona
überschlagen sich.
Etwas Angst um den Betrieb,
wie lange Sie durchhalten können?
Absolut,
es ist immer eine Angst vorhanden.
Ich trage auch eine Verantwortung
für die Unternehmung.
Wie würden Sie die Angst beschreiben?
Als Mann ist es immer schwierig,
Angst zu beschreiben.
Ich merke die Angst insofern,
dass ich schlechter schlafe,
dass ich mehr Gespräche brauche -
mit meiner Frau,
meinen Bereichsleitern.
Thermoplan.
Das Unternehmen in der Innerschweiz
produziert für den Weltmarkt.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Kaffeemaschinen für Marken
wie Starbucks und Nespresso
werden hier gefertigt.
Was steht als Erstes an?
Einen Kaffee trinken.
Italiens Fabriken sind zu -
und von dort stammen viele Teile.
Wie prekär ist es für Sie,
dass die Fabriken
in Italien und im Tessin schliessen?
Tatsache ist: Wenn wir
keine Komponenten mehr erhalten,
werden wir
höchstwahrscheinlich nach Ostern
Teile der Produktion
nicht mehr aufrechterhalten können.
Wie viel fällt dann weg?
Es betrifft
fast alle Maschinenlinien.
Ich würde sagen ...
Etwa 70 % der Produkte könnten
nicht mehr hergestellt werden.
Das wär dramatisch, nicht?
- Sehr dramatisch.
Wie war dein Wochenende, Stefan?
Mit den gestrigen Nachrichten
aus Italien und dem Tessin
war es recht anspruchsvoll.
Sie schrieben gestern,
dass sie versuchen,
die betroffenen Lieferanten
zu erreichen.
Das ist natürlich schwierig,
denn sie sind mit ihren
eigenen Betrieben auch gefordert.
Sind Kinder und Frau happy?
Es war schwierig, am Donnerstag
starb meine Schwiegermutter.
Das hat das Wochenende
natürlich auch geprägt.
Es war doppelt schwierig.
400 Angestellte arbeiten hier.
Hallo miteinander.
Guten Morgen miteinander.
Hallo.
Haben wir noch genügend Teile?
- Ja.
Es wird langsam knapp.
15 % der Belegschaft fehlen -
v.a. Mitarbeitende,
die zu den Risikogruppen gehören.
Es ist manchmal schon etwas mühsam,
denn man lebt
mit einer ständigen Angst.
Wenn man arbeiten geht,
weiss man nie,
was es Neues zum Thema gibt.
Man macht sich Gedanken,
wie die Zukunft aussieht,
wie es mit Thermoplan weitergeht.
Man hat sehr viele offene Fragen.
Mein Mann
arbeitet auf der Baustelle,
meine Mutter im Coop -
die müssen auch alle arbeiten gehen.
Also wieso sollte ich nicht ... Ja.
Es ist auch eine Ablenkung.
Man kann ja nicht nur zu Hause
sitzen und sich Gedanken machen.
Bis vor Kurzem, bis einer positiv
auf Corona getestet wurde,
habe ich mich wohlgefühlt.
Ich ging ganz normal arbeiten.
Mit der Zeit beginne ich,
mir Gedanken zu machen.
Wenn die Corona-Fälle zunehmen,
würde ich mich wohler fühlen,
wenn ich zu Hause bleiben könnte.
Ein Mitarbeiter habe das Virus
im österreichischen Skiort Ischgl
aufgelesen, sagt Adrian Steiner.
Unterdessen sei er wieder gesund
und arbeite im Homeoffice.
Was mich sehr beschäftigt:
Wir haben Mitarbeitende,
die im Homeoffice arbeiten können,
die eher administrative Tätigkeiten
erledigen.
Aber in der Produktion,
in der Montage
ist die Anwesenheit erforderlich.
Ich kann den Mitarbeitenden
keine Komponenten nach Hause geben,
um sie zu montieren.
Somit setze ich
die Produktionsmitarbeitenden
einer grösseren Gefahr aus -
das beschäftigt mich.
Was überlegen Sie sich diesbezüglich?
Wir haben eine neue Situation
mit den Zulieferpartnern in Italien.
Deshalb könnte eine Schliessung
der Produktion in Weggis
ein mögliches Szenario sein.
Das überlegen Sie sich, um proaktiv
die Mitarbeiter zu schützen?
Das ist einer der Aspekte.
Eine Schliessung von zwei Wochen
oder länger?
Sagen Sie mir das -
ich weiss es nicht.
Es ist echt Wahnsinn!
Der Verlauf ist fast überhängend.
Einerseits
möchte man es gar nichts sehen.
Aber wenn man es ignoriert,
erlebt man eine böse Überraschung.
Das sind eben auch Tatsachen,
die wir in unsere Entscheidungen
integrieren wollen und müssen.
Diese Situation
fühlt sich nicht gut an.
Ich spüre es oftmals bei mir selber,
wenn es eine Kumulierung
verschiedener Dinge gibt -
dann bin ich auch nicht entspannt
und superpositiv.
Aber ich versuche es.
Ist es die schwierigste Phase,
seit Sie hier Chef sind?
Das gab es noch nie,
dass Gesundheit und Wirtschaft
in einer Krise verschmelzen.
Das ist aussergewöhnlich.
Jason?
- Hey, how are you?
Hello, Jason.
Das erste Mal ohne Maske -
ah, jetzt mit.
Skypen
mit seinem chinesischen Partner.
How are you?
- I'm good, I'm good.
Ohne das kann ich
nirgendwo hingehen.
Du bist grün.
Grün heisst, dass ich nie
an einen gefährlichen Ort gehe.
Wenn ich nach Taipeh gehe,
wird es gelb.
Dann muss ich
14 Tage zu Hause bleiben.
Sehr konsequent.
Wir sind überwältigt
von den Ereignissen in Italien.
This is not far away
from Switzerland.
Wir erleben schwierige Zeiten,
weil wir
viel weniger schnell handeln -
verglichen mit euch.
Das ist keine normale Krankheit,
sie ist sehr leicht übertragbar.
Was schlägst du vor?
Soll ich die Firma schliessen?
Ich empfehle euch:
Halbiert die Belegschaft.
50 % im Betrieb, 50 % zu Hause.
Und nach zwei Wochen wechseln.
Thank you.
Bye, bye. Bye, Jason.
Als wir vor vier Wochen
telefonierten
und sie alle verhüllt waren,
Schutzmasken und -brillen
trugen,
nahmen wir es nicht ernst.
Und schau uns heute an.
Jetzt sind wir gefordert.
Sein Markt zieht wieder an,
er hat opportunities.
Und wir denken
über eine Schliessung nach.
Den Ansatz fifty-fifty
finde ich nicht so schlecht.
Anderseits wissen wir alle,
dass wir mit der Optimierung
der letzten Jahre
nicht die Kapazität haben,
dass die Hälfte zu Hause bleibt.
Die Produktivität wird
fast nicht aufrechtzuerhalten sein.
Maschinen
für den Grosskunden Starbucks.
Doch aus den USA
die nächste Hiobsbotschaft:
Starbucks muss Filialen schliessen.
Ist die Gesundheitsbehörde
national organisiert?
Aha, auf kommunaler Ebene.
- Darum ist alles unklar.
Das macht alles
noch viel komplizierter.
Thank you. Bye, bye. Bye.
Es ist auch für Starbucks
eine Blackbox.
Er sagt, wir sollen uns auf
den asiatischen Markt fokussieren.
Wir sollen die Produktionskapazität,
die wir für Amerika
reserviert hatten,
vorsorglich
eher für Asien einplanen.
Amerika gar nicht mehr beliefern?
Er hat die Bestellungen noch offen,
sie noch nicht gecancelt.
Könnte er das?
Aber nach diesem Gespräch
müssen wir davon ausgehen.
* Asiatische, tröpfelnde Klänge *
Massimo Bonzi hat inzwischen
umgestellt auf Take-away.
Für den 1. April
haben wir uns etwas Neues überlegt.
Damit die Leute auch sehen,
dass die Osteria Santo Bevitore
noch offen ist.
Unsere neue Idee: ein Take-away.
Mal schauen, wie es funktioniert.
Allora!
* Gemächliche Klänge *
Wir müssen erst schauen,
wie die Leute reagieren.
Im Moment bieten viele Restaurants
Take-away an.
Wir tun dies nicht,
um Geld damit zu verdienen.
Es ist für uns -
immerhin haben wir so etwas zu tun.
Jetzt plötzlich zwei Monate lang
jeden Abend zu Hause -
das ist ein ganz anderes Leben.
Die ganze Familie hilft.
Wir waren beide zu Hause.
Das war schon schwierig,
aber bis jetzt ging alles gut.
Es ist schwierig mit dir,
den Kindern, mit allem.
Eh, è più bello di così.
Abbiamo il tempo. Che pasticcio.
Finanziell ist es tragisch.
Wir müssen die Miete bezahlen.
Das Personal hat Kurzarbeit.
Du musst aber trotzdem zahlen ...
... i contributi,
come si chiamano in tedesco?
Sozialleistungen.
- ... Sozialleistungen.
Zum Glück haben wir in den letzten
acht Jahren wirklich gut gearbeitet,
wir haben gute Reserven.
Es ist einfach schade,
wenn sie so aufgebraucht werden.
Es ist etwas,
das jeden Restaurateur ...
Ich glaube, irgendwann
müssen wir wieder anfangen.
Sonst machen wir alles zu.
Allora. Terri!
La panna!
Prego, capo, tieni.
- Grazie, amore.
Dove?
Allora, questo è il bologna,
mon amour.
Poi abbiamo la panna.
Okay. I Paccheri.
Schlimm.
Diesen Monat ist es sicher
eine halbe Million weniger Umsatz.
Alle Kunden, die weg sind.
Hai fame?
Il tartufo.
Toscano, San Miniato.
Heute war der erste Tag
mit Take-away.
Null. Kein einziger Kunde. Null!
Eh, niente. Oggi lo faccio,
al limite mangiamo noi e via.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
(Daniel Koch) Gemäss heutigen
Informationen aus dem Tessin
ist es wirklich dramatisch.
Sie kämpfen, jetzt
Intensivbettenstationen zu haben.
... vielleicht ein Ausgangsverbot
oder eine Ausgangseinschränkung
wie z.B. im Kanton Uri,
wo über 65-Jährige nur noch
in Spezialfällen rausdürfen.
Wir wissen, dass sich das Virus
im Moment weiterverbreitet.
Deshalb haben wir
heute Morgen beschlossen,
die sozialen Kontakte
weiter einzuschränken,
um die Ausbreitung des Virus
zu bremsen.- Dann tut es auch!
... werden
die spontanen Versammlungen
von mehr als fünf Personen
im öffentlichen Raum verboten,
im gesamten Land.
- Das ist immer noch zu viel.
Die "spontanen" - was heisst das?
Wenn man sich
auf der Strasse begegnet?
Sie müssen doch einfach
alle Kontakte verbieten.
Das ist das einzige, was nützt:
Ausgangssperre.
Diese Idioten
sitzen immer noch draussen,
spielen auf dem Spielplatz
und trinken ein Bier.
Eigentlich ist es sinnlos,
was wir hier machen.
Es bringt nicht viel.
Der Bundesrat will keine
Ausgangssperre für die Schweiz.
Zu unserer Freiheit
gehört auch die Bewegungsfreiheit.
Dafür brauchen wir aber
die Mithilfe der ganzen Bevölkerung.
Ehrlich: Ich habe mehr Härte
und Grösse der Schweizer erwartet.
Ich meine - seit einer Woche
passiert nichts.
Die Leute sind immer noch draussen.
Das wäre die Möglichkeit gewesen,
zu sagen: "Bleibt alle zu Hause."
Jetzt haben wir die Beschränkung
auf fünf Personen.
Wir begannen bei 50, dann zehn,
jetzt fünf.
Das löst unser Problem nicht.
Wir müssen radikal handeln.
Daniel Kochs Hunde
sind zurück aus dem Hundehort.
Sie helfen natürlich in der Krise.
Ich muss mit ihnen raus, spazieren.
Und etwa einmal die Woche
machen wir etwas Sport.
Nicht so lange.
15-30 Min. vielleicht.
Das ist ... Erholung pur.
Rechts! Rechts!
Kurz vor der Krise hat er sich
noch eine weitere Hündin gekauft.
Sie war vorgesehen
für die Zeit nach Corona.
Sie ist wirklich noch jung
und natürlich völlig unbändig.
Sie bräuchte noch etwas Erziehung.
Dafür habe ich jetzt keine Zeit.
Deshalb wird sie wohl
ein etwas unerzogener Hund.
Daniel Koch: Jahrelang arbeitete er
in Afrika als IKRK-Delegierter,
u.a. in Sierra Leone
während des Bürgerkriegs.
Zurück in der Schweiz
kämpfte er gegen die SARS-Pandemie.
Guten Morgen.
Und jetzt plötzlich
steht er im Rampenlicht.
Es ist natürlich etwas ungewohnt,
plötzlich so viel Aufmerksamkeit.
Viele Leute sprechen mich an.
Es ist sehr ungewohnt.
Wenn die Leute immer noch
dieselben Fragen haben,
muss man halt nochmals antworten
und nochmals erklären.
Etwas vom Wichtigsten ist, dass die
Bevölkerung weiss, worum es geht.
Solche Ereignisse und Krankheiten
sind Gott sei Dank nicht so häufig.
Dass es jetzt so stark gekommen ist,
war vielleicht ...
wieder mal an der Zeit.
Es ist schwer zu sagen.
Die Natur hat halt
immer wieder Überraschungen parat.
Jedes Land, jede Gesellschaft
muss mit dem Problem so umgehen,
wie es dem Land
und der Gesellschaft entspricht.
Wir versuchen es
auf unsere schweizerische Art.
Das heisst?
Den Leuten erklären.
Nicht extrem sein.
Und versuchen, die Situation
zusammen mit der Bevölkerung
zu meistern.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
In ca. 5 Min. wird der erste
Corona-Patient eingeliefert.
* Gedämpftes Stimmengewirr *
Der erste Patient
wird jetzt intubiert.
Er hat Atemnot,
ist unter 100 % Sauerstoff.
Damit hat er schlechte Blutgase.
Aber er ist sicher gut versorgt,
weil sich
so viele Leute um ihn kümmern.
Das kommt alles gut.
Es ist so: Im Moment reicht
Ihre Lungenfunktion nicht aus,
um genug Sauerstoff aufzunehmen.
Das ist über längere Zeit
schlecht für Ihr Herz,
weil Sie da
auch eine Krankheit haben.
Deshalb sind Sie auf
die Intensivstation verlegt worden.
Die Beatmung ist sehr schwierig.
Das Problem ist es nicht,
Luft in den Patienten zu bringen -
das kann man mit viel Gewalt -,
sondern man muss es schonend
und sanft machen,
um die Lunge
nicht zusätzlich zu schädigen.
Das ist schlussendlich
das Schwierige.
* Angespannte Klänge *
Ich glaube, es läuft gut.
Es sind sehr viele Menschen,
die gerade
diverse Aufgaben erledigen,
und die Koordination
ist etwas schwierig.
Aber ich glaube, das regelt sich
gerade alles, pendelt sich ein.
Also vorsichtig zuversichtlich?
Vorsichtig zuversichtlich.
(Daniel Koch) Wir haben
weiterhin steigende Fallzahlen,
8'000 wurden positiv getestet
und leider
verstarben schon 70 Personen.
* Freizeichen *
Amt für Wirtschaft und Arbeit?
Grüezi, hier Schaub.
- Grüezi, Frau Schaub.
Ich habe eine Frage:
Ich bin Coiffeuse
und weiss nicht genau,
was ich jetzt tun soll oder kann.
Ganz klar: Im Prinzip können Sie
im Moment gar nichts machen.
Sie müssen abwarten.
- Okay.
Sie müssen abwarten,
was uns der Bundesrat mitteilt,
hoffentlich heute
irgendwann am Nachmittag.
Dann wird er kommunizieren,
ob Sie von Kurzarbeit
profitieren
bzw. eine Entschädigung
bekommen können.
Okay. Für Kurzarbeit anmelden
kann ich mich oder nicht?
Nein, noch nicht.
Es ist unklar, ob es
über Kurzarbeit läuft. - Okay.
D.h. für mich konkret:
abwarten und Tee trinken.
Einmal mehr -
eigentlich seit Dienstag.
Abwarten, Tee trinken, hoffen,
dass das Beste daraus gemacht wird.
Die leere Primarschule Oberuster.
Einzig Schulleiter Ernesto Archer
und ein Mitarbeiter sind noch hier.
Sie bereiten Laptops
zur Ausleihe vor.
Das sind die Formulare.
Hier schreibst du
die Inventarnummer hin.
Soll ich die Liste öffnen?
- Ja, die brauche ich.
Es ist dieser Laptop.
- Der hier?
Anja Kauf holt zusammen
mit ihrem Sohn einen Laptop ab.
Das Passwort hast du im Handy?
Nein, ich weiss es auswendig.
Zu Hause haben wir
nicht so viele Computer.
Mein Bruder braucht einen,
meine Schwester, meine Mutter auch.
Wir müssen ... ja.
Jetzt hast du deinen eigenen?
- Ja.
Ich habe drei Kinder.
Es ist etwas schwierig,
sie zu motivieren,
über Stunden daran zu arbeiten.
Gehen wir heim.
- Tschüss.
Mama?
Ja, Finn?
Musst du dich wieder einloggen?
Nein, warte.
Was hatten wir?
Unten ist das Passwort.
Jetzt bist du drin.
- Thank you.
Machst du davon? Eine halbe Stunde.
Nicht?
Etwas anderes.
- Etwas anderes?
Meine Mutter ist meine Lehrerin.
Manchmal aber auch mein Vater.
Denn manchmal
muss meine Mutter zur Arbeit.
Die Lehrer
haben am Wochenende gearbeitet
und einige Nachrichten geschickt.
Ich muss noch einiges ausdrucken.
Bald muss die Pflegefachfrau
wieder ins Spital zur Arbeit.
Es ist mehr die Ungewissheit,
wie es weitergeht.
Kommt der Peak,
von dem alle reden, oder nicht?
Mama?
- Ja?
"Discord went away."
- Müssen wir es neu öffnen?
Werden wir überrannt,
12-Std.-Schichten schieben müssen?
Es ist eher angespannt.
Ah, no. I have it again.
- Okay, super.
* Unruhige, tänzelnde Klänge *
Ich finde,
sie sind viel zu wenig draussen.
Das macht mir am meisten Sorgen:
Sie haben kaum Bewegung.
Dann kommt die ganze Energie.
Und wie ist es mit eurer Energie?
Ja ...
Wir haben mehr Zeit.
- Ja, aber auch mehr Streit.
Ja.
V.a. am Anfang
gab es sehr viele Reibungen.
Sonst gehe ich immer zu einem Freund
mit Tischtennistisch.
Aber jetzt darf ich natürlich nicht.
Vermisst du ihn?
- Ja, schon etwas.
Mama, es ist Mittagszeit.
Das habe ich auch gemacht.
- Schon Mittag?
Oh-o, schon 12 Uhr. Gut,
ich muss es nur aufwärmen, Finn.
Hilfst du Tisch decken?
- Okay.
Es geht nicht,
ich kann es nicht abkürzen.
Das ist erst im Aufbau, du musst
Geduld haben mit deinen Lehrern.
Tinu, was machst du da?
- Ping-Pong-Challenge.
Wie geht das?
Man muss mit dem Schläger und Ball
versuchen, durchs Loch zu schiessen.
Hat das schon mal geklappt?
Einmal habe ich es geschafft.
- Essen!
Setzt euch.
Was, nicht gut?
- Doch.
Kleben sie? Ich habe Butter
rangemacht.- Mama, can you help me?
Bis wann
musst du den Aufsatz abgeben?
Keine Ahnung.
- Ich glaube, Mittwoch, 1. April.
Es sind immer alle hier.
Es ist schon kompliziert manchmal.
Wenn wir uns nicht verstehen.
Die Teenage-Zeit ist schwierig,
wenn alle zusammen sind.
Wenn sie sprechen,
dann stritten sie.
Streiten.
- Streiten. Thank you.
Wir müssen also Polizei sein,
dschütsch ...
Judge.
- ... Judge sein ...
... Krankenschwester
und alles zusammen.
Und Lehrer.
- Lehrer, genau.
Es gibt keinen Helpdesk.
Wir müssen also schnell lernen.
Wer macht den Abwasch?
- Ich.
Wenn du es laufen lässt,
wird es heiss.
Es ist immer ein Kampf.
Normalerweise
machen sie den Abwasch nicht.
Wenn sie zur Schule gehen,
reicht das nicht.
Seit einer Woche müssen sie aber
beim Abwasch mithelfen.
Das ist etwas Gutes,
das das Virus brachte:
Wir bleiben hier.
Wir müssen reden.
Wir können besprechen,
was gut ist und was nicht.
Es gibt keine Möglichkeit,
wegzugehen, keine Alternative.
Wir müssen hier bleiben.
Das ist sehr gut -
für uns das Beste.
(Simonetta Sommaruga) Die 10 Mrd.,
die der Bundesrat gesprochen hat,
sind als Soforthilfe zu verstehen.
Der Bundesrat weiss, dass es
noch mehr Mittel brauchen wird.
(Ueli Maurer)
Der Bund stellt 20 Mrd. Kredite
zur Verfügung für Bürgschaften.
(Guy Parmelin) Über 40 Mrd. Fr.
Das ist die Summe, die im Moment
für die betroffenen Menschen
die Wirtschaft der Schweiz
zur Verfügung steht.
Es ist schon angenehmer, dass
man weiss: Es wird einem geholfen.
Man sucht sich ein Tagesziel.
Ich auf jeden Fall, damit mir
die Decke nicht auf den Kopf fällt.
Ich probiere so gut wie möglich,
den Alltag beizubehalten.
Damit ich
irgendwie eine Struktur habe.
Zum einen arbeite ich sehr gern.
Das fehlt mir sehr - ebenso
wie der Kontakt mit den Leuten.
Ich bin eigentlich nur zu Hause.
Ich muss zu Hause
irgendwie die Zeit totschlagen.
Ich habe alles geputzt,
ich weiss nicht mehr, was tun.
Wenn das weitergeht, muss ich mir
alles wieder neu zusammenstellen.
* Abwartende Klänge *
Hallo.
- (Verschiedene) Hallo.
Ich kann eure Hallos nicht
auseinanderhalten, aber hallo.
(Junge) Wir müssen alle ruhig sein,
wie im Unterricht, die Hand heben.
Erst muss ich alle hören.
Habt ihr alle
die Mathe-Sachen vor euch?
(Mehrere) Ja.
Zwischen Lehrerin Melania Marti und
ihrer fünften Primarklasse in Uster
liegen 20 km.
Dieselben Regeln wie in der Schule:
Nur jemand spricht.
Ihr habt euch diese Woche
mit dem Thema Runden beschäftigt.
Scheisse.
Hört ihr mich noch?
* Knistern der Leitung *
Wer will etwas sagen?
* Unverständlich *
Was hast du gesagt?
(Mit Unterbrüchen)
Wenn ich das mit Zahlen ...
Wieso stellt das immer ab?
Habt ihr mich gehört?
- (Mehrere) Nein.
Meine Frage war:
Was muss man gut können?
Dezimalzahlen.
War das Ramona?
Also.
Was ... ähm.
Ihr Ehemann, ebenfalls im Homeoffice,
kommt ihr zu Hilfe.
(Flüstert) Das Mikrofon ...
Die ganze Zeit!
Natürlich nicht, wenn du hier bist.
Logisch.
(Mädchen) Frau Marti?
- Ja?
Muss man es ins Heft zeichnen?
- Egal, irgendwo.
Nimm einfach ein Blatt.
(Mädchen) Frau Marti?
- (Junge) Nimm einfach ein Blatt.
(Mädchen) Was muss ich machen?
Siehst du? Hier, schau.
Bis wohin muss man?
- Können sie dich muten?
Das kann man z.T.
- Nein.
... einem Finger.
Okay. Meine Lieben, jemand von euch
schaltet mich immer stumm.
Kann das sein?
Praktisch, wenn man
den IT-Support zu Hause hat.
Es ist sehr praktisch,
wenn man so unterstützt wird.
Ich denke immer: "die armen Eltern,
die das nicht haben."
Ich bin sehr froh.
Er musste mich
schon einige Male retten.
Dann brechen wir die Übung hier ab.
Schön, dass ihr vorbeigeschaut habt.
Danke, gute Arbeit!
Tschüss zusammen.
- (Mehrere) Ade, Frau Marti.
Eine Lehrerin
am Rande des Nervenzusammenbruchs?
Jetzt war es gerade etwas tricky.
Irgendwas ... Man kann sich da-
zwischenfunken und lautlos stellen.
Ich glaube, die einen machten das -
wohl aus Versehen.
Deshalb hörte man mich oft nicht.
Ich glaube, was sicher helfen wird:
Wenn wir ein Mittel
für Videoanrufe haben.
Sodass ich z.B. etwas zeigen kann.
Damit ich eine Einführungslektion
am Computer mit allen machen kann.
Das geht momentan noch nicht.
* Anrufton *
Marti?
Hallo?
- Hallo?
Hier ist Hassan.
- Hoi, Hassan. Guten Morgen.
Ich bin gerade ins Discord rein,
aber da steht "Freunde hinzufügen".
Was muss ich machen?
Freunde hinzufügen?
Da musst du nichts machen.
Siehst du rechts alle,
die schon miteinander schreiben?
(Frau) Nein, da ist nichts.
- Nichts.
Vielleicht sind wir falsch rein.
Ich kriege Anrufe von Eltern, die
etwas nicht installieren konnten ...
Es ist schon sehr herausfordernd.
V.a. bin ich
völlig darauf angewiesen,
dass Eltern oder Kinder
helfen können,
die Programme zu installieren,
ein Word-Dokument abzuspeichern
und zu mailen.
Das ist sehr herausfordernd
für gewisse Eltern und Kinder.
Du weisst, dass du auch mich
bei Fragen immer anrufen darfst.
Mache ich.- Wenn du mal
nicht auf Papi warten magst.
Denn ich warte auch zu Hause darauf,
dass mich jemand
für Erklärungen braucht.
Hören wir uns später. Tschüss!
* Angespannte Klänge *
Unser Auftrag ist, Patienten,
die mit Verdacht kommen, zu testen.
Wir sind sehr dankbar für den
Assistenzdienst der Schweizer Armee.
Wir konnten Personal von uns,
vom Unispital abziehen.
Es wird jetzt 1:1
durch die Soldaten ersetzt.
Auch anderswo
sind die Soldaten im Einsatz.
Es ist ganz anders als im WK.
Speziell sind die Schutzmassnahmen.
Die Hygienemassnahmen
sind nochmals deutlich strikter.
Geht es Ihnen gut?
- Besser.
Sehr gut. 125 auf 80.
98 % Sauerstoffsättigung.
Perfekt.
- Super.
Sauerstoffsättigung ...
Die Arbeit des Pflegepersonals
sieht er nun mit anderen Augen.
Sie haben sehr viel Stress.
Lange Arbeitstage ...
Ich habe grossen Respekt.
Wenn man das mal
am eigenen Leib erfährt.
Man merkt sofort,
dass es kein WK ist.
Organisatorisch
lief es auch ganz anders ab.
Da es ein ernster Einsatz ist,
ist die Motivation der Soldaten
viel grösser.
Die Kameradschaft
ist auch noch mal grösser.
Die Maske ist mir runtergerutscht.
Thermoplan Weggis.
Für Geschäftsführer Adrian Steiner
ist nicht mehr der Lockdown
in Italien das grosse Problem,
sondern die Lage im eigenen Betrieb.
Wir hatten leider einen Verdachts-
fall mehr in der Produktion.
Heute werden wir das Resultat ...
Die Person wurde gestern getestet.
Heute werden wir
den Bescheid erhalten,
ob sie positiv
oder hoffentlich negativ ist.
Jeden Tag
verändert sich die Ausgangslage.
Das ist anspruchsvoll
fürs Team, die Organisation.
Tom, du bist virtuell dabei.
Herzlich willkommen
zum Mittwoch-Update,
zum Corona-Dashboard.
Wir sehen die Entwicklung der Fälle.
Die Definition, wann ...
... wir eine Schliessung
in Betracht ziehen:
Wenn wir innert einer Woche
drei bestätigte Fälle haben.
Wenn wir die Selbstquarantäne
dreimal machen,
mit allen Personen,
die in Kontakt waren usw. ...
Das würde uns eh
zu einem grossen Teil ...
... in der Produktivität
beeinträchtigen.
Ich finde es gut, eine Zahl
festzulegen. Also diese drei.
Dass man dann etwas unternehmen.
Eine Gesamtschliessung
wegen eines Falls
wäre mit heutigem Wissen
überreagiert.
Anders gefragt: Nur schon in diesem
Raum sassen heute sieben Personen,
plus wir drei vom Fernsehen.
Man sagt: keine Versammlungen
über fünf Personen.
Geht das überhaupt noch, oder
setzen wir uns einem Risiko aus?
Sie haben schon Recht.
Es ist ein Risiko.
Darf man noch mehr als fünf Personen
in einem Raum haben?
Bei uns muss man am Schnitttisch
Masken tragen, wenn man zu zweit ist.
Ja, ein guter Punkt.
Die Unsicherheit ...
Mir macht das auch Angst.
Ihnen weniger? Als Unternehmer darf
man auch nicht zu viel Angst haben?
Ich zeige sie nicht.
Ich spüre es aber in meinem Umfeld.
Wenn ich morgens das Haus verlasse,
merke ich, wie es
meine Frau und Kinder belastet.
Wenn ich gehe und mich
der potenziellen Gefahr aussetze.
Meine Frau ist sicher vorsichtiger.
Und sehr wahrscheinlich
ängstlicher als ich.
Anruf bei der BAG-Hotline.
Er will Klarheit
über Sitzungen in Zeiten von Corona.
Ja, diese Hotline.
(Mann) Aufgrund
des zunehmenden Informationsbedarfs
haben wir viele Anrufe und
entschuldigen uns für die Wartezeit.
In der Schweiz nimmt das Risiko zu,
sich mit dem neuen Coronavirus
anzustecken.
Das neue Coronavirus
wird hauptsächlich
bei engem und längerem Kontakt
übertragen.
Er geht
zu den Mitarbeitern von Alessio,
dem Mann mit Verdacht auf Corona.
Es fällt immer wieder jemand aus,
dann heisst es: arbeiten für zwei.
Der Fall vom Montag ...
Heute kriegen wir Bescheid,
ob der Mitarbeitende
positiv oder negativ ist.
Du warst ja in seiner Nähe
hier im Wareneingangsbereich.
Belastet dich das?
Nicht unbedingt. Ich bin
nicht in der Risikogruppe.
Ich bin noch zu jung.
Wir standen nicht nahe beeinander,
von daher: Nein.
Weiss man hier, dass Alessio ...
- Nein.
Ich hörte vorhin
zum ersten Mal davon.
Steiner will erst alle informieren,
wenn ein Verdachtsfall
positiv getestet ist.
Das wären vielleicht 20 Leute, die
man alle in Quarantäne setzen müsste?
Informieren ...
Sie wissen ja selbst,
wie lange sie Kontakt hatten.
Dann entscheiden wir zusammen,
wo Selbstquarantäne sinnvoll ist.
Der Mitarbeitende soll entscheiden,
ob es für ihn besser ist,
zu Hause zu bleiben?- Absolut.
Ich habe das BAG erreicht.
Es war interessant:
Sie sagten, die Gruppe sollte nicht
grösser als fünf Personen sein.
Das gilt also auch für Sitzungen.
- Okay.
Wir können das virtuell machen,
zwei, drei draussen.
Genau.
- Super.
Dann ein Anruf der Personalchefin.
Ja, es wird uns nicht langweilig.
Sie versucht,
Alessio zu kontaktieren,
ob er etwas gehört habe.
In der Zwischenzeit
hat sich am Mittag ergeben,
dass ein anderer Mitarbeiter der
Abteilung Forschung & Entwicklung
jetzt Symptome hat.
Er ist nun mit Fieber usw.
nach Hause gegangen.
Der Arzt hat ihm,
seiner Frau und den Zwillingen
zehn Tage Quarantäne verschrieben.
Der Test ist
noch nicht angeordnet worden.
Wir müssen warten
mit Informieren und Kommunizieren.
Wir kommunizieren erst,
wenn es bestätigt ist.
Die Personalchefin
meldet sich erneut.
Er hat es wirklich nicht. Definitiv?
Gott sei Dank.
Ich kam auch leicht ins Straucheln.
Wenn er ... Jede Theorie,
die wir diskutierten ...
Nützt die Selbstquarantäne
überhaupt?
Dann muss man alles hinterfragen.
Machen wir so weiter wie gehabt.
Und beruhigen die Leute.
Tschüss, Brigitte.
Also: Positiv. Er ist negativ.
Der Test war negativ.
- Ah, super.
Die Geduld und die Nerven
nicht verlieren.
Das BAG ist mein roter Faden.
Es ist mein Grashalm,
an den ich mich klammere.
Ich setze alles daran,
dass ich den nicht verliere.
Obwohl es
manchmal nicht einfach ist.
Ich wollte kurz
zum Fall von Alessio informieren:
Er ist nicht positiv
getestet worden.
Alle, die mit ihm in Kontakt waren:
keine Gefahr.
Super.
- Gut, vielen Dank.
(Alain Berset)
Bitte bleibt zu Hause.
Es wäre für alle gut,
wenn es an Ostern
mal keinen Stau am Gotthard gäbe.
(Daniel Koch)
Im Moment sind 280 Patienten
unter einem Beatmungsgerät.
Das ist für eine Schweiz
doch enorm viel.
Wenn man sich das vorstellt:
Das sind 280 Patienten,
die um ihr Leben kämpfen.
Und Hunderte Pflegende,
die das ermöglichen.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Alle bereit?
90°. Eins, zwei, drei.
Wir haben heute Samstag,
den 28. März.
Ich war gerade auf dem neuen B-Hof.
Da haben wir drei Patienten.
Ganz ruhig atmen.
Die Hand fest drücken.
Sie sind auf der Intensivstation.
Es sind
sehr anstrengende Zeiten im Moment.
Die Patienten
sind sehr, sehr instabil.
Sehr, sehr aufwendig.
Jetzt hatten wir gerade
eine Reanimation.
Im Moment erfolgreich,
evtl. müssen wir sogar operieren
auf der Intensivstation.
An einem anderen Bett, gleichzeitig,
eine Einlage einer externen Lunge,
einer ECMO.
Wir sind extrem am Rotieren.
Der ist jetzt gar noch nicht gut.
Der braucht noch Zeit.
(Daniel Koch) Wir haben weiterhin
konstant steigende Zahlen.
Das hier ist das typische Bild:
Patient in Bauchlage.
Teilweise
wirklich schwierig zu beatmen.
Es braucht sehr viel Aufwand,
sehr viel Pflege.
Aber meist hilft das auch viel.
Wir müssen gewisse Tiefen,
Talsohlen, die wir durchschreiten,
einfach akzeptieren und durchhalten.
Das braucht teils sehr viel
psychische Kraft und Ressourcen.
Man denkt oft: "Jetzt
geht es dann gleich nicht mehr".
Und irgendwann wird es dann
wieder ein bisschen besser.
Kurze Frage, wir haben eine Anfrage
aus dem Kantonsspital Chur
zur Übernahme eines Patienten,
bei dem es Beatmungsprobleme gibt.
Zurzeit braucht er ECMO noch nicht,
vielleicht kommen wir darum herum,
wenn wir ihn übernehmen.
Ist aber ausserkantonal.
Du bist ja mit der GD in Kontakt.
Gut, vielen Dank, tschüss!
Okay. Es wird kompliziert.
* Drängende Klänge *
Wir erwarten noch mehr Patienten,
wohl ab Anfang nächster Woche.
Es wäre natürlich gut,
einen Testlauf zu haben,
um zu schauen, ob wir alles bereit
haben, was wir vorbereitet haben.
* Drängende Klänge *
Wir haben ein Riesenglück
im Kanton Zürich.
Die peripheren Spitäler
machen eine gute Arbeit,
übernehmen sehr viele Patienten.
Wäre das nicht so, hätten wir am
Unispital wohl ganz andere Zustände.
Die helfen uns sehr,
und dafür bin ich sehr dankbar.
Im Moment sind unsere Zahlen stabil.
Ich hoffe sehr, dass es so bleibt.
Darum: Bitte keine weiteren
Ansteckungen! Bitte passen Sie auf!
Bitte bleiben Sie zu Hause!
Halten Sie die 2 m Abstand ein!
Gehen Sie trotz schönen Wetters
nicht in der Gruppe draussen feiern!
Machen Sie auch zu Hause
in der Wohnung keine Einladungen,
bleiben Sie unter sich!
* Kirchenglocken *
Naters im Oberwallis.
Trauerfeier für Tini Gertschen.
* Orgelspiel *
Wegen Corona dürfen
nur zwölf Personen teilnehmen.
Die Kirche mit 500 Sitzplätzen
ist praktisch leer.
Im Namen des Vaters, des Sohnes
und des Heiligen Geistes: Amen.
Im Namen von allen,
die gerne hier wären.
die euch mittragen,
in eurer Trauer
und im Glauben ans Wiedersehen.
Im Namen von ihnen allen: unser
aufrichtiges und herzliches Beileid.
Der Herr ist mit euch.
Ich glaube,
was die Verwandten in dieser Familie
und in allen Trauerfamilien
im Moment zeichnet, ist,
dass niemand da ist,
der ihnen das Beileid wünschen kann.
In der Messe stehe ich als Pfarrer
zwar vorne wie immer.
Aber die Angehörigen
sind weiter auseinander
als sonst bei Beerdigungen,
wo sie einander
auch mal in die Arme nehmen können.
Uns sie spüren:
Hinter uns sind die Bänke leer.
Das fehlt jetzt in der Kirche,
in der Trauerphase stark.
Man spürt als Trauerfamilie:
Wir sind alleine.
Es gibt wohl viele Leute in der
Pfarrei, die für die Familie beten,
aber sie können
es nicht physisch zeigen.
Die Trauerfeier
wird per Livestream übertragen.
Wer nicht in die Kirche darf,
kann im Internet dabei sein.
* Kirchenglocken *
Auch das Traueressen entfällt.
Man sitzt sonst zusammen,
isst zusammen.
Meist ist am Schluss
auch eine relativ gelöste Stimmung.
Es ist dann ein Zeichen: Wir sind
im Leben, und das Leben geht weiter.
Das fehlt. Aber es fehlt
auch das im kleinen Rahmen.
Heute als Familie würden wir
zumindest nach der Urnenbeisetzung
noch einen Kaffee trinken gehen
oder zusammen Mittag essen.
Das kann man einfach nicht.
Auch Eugen Habegger
leidet unter dem Alleinsein.
Ich habe angefangen, mehr zu lesen.
Ich kann ja nicht die ganze Zeit
vor dem Affenkasten sitzen.
Ganz schlimm ist,
dass ich nicht mehr
zu meiner Frau ins Pflegeheim kann.
Ich bin praktisch jeden Tag
zu ihr gegangen.
Wir sind jetzt in einem Alter ...
Sie wurde 92,
und ich werde dieses Jahr 91.
Da muss man schon schauen,
wie man zurechtkommt.
Wie lange haben Sie Ihre Frau
nicht mehr gesehen?
Seit der Sperre vor zwei Wochen.
Davor war ich jeden Tag bei ihr.
Seither telefonieren wir jeden Tag.
Letzte Woche haben wir mal geskypt,
da konnten wir uns sehen,
aber das ist
natürlich nicht dasselbe.
Gibt es etwas,
was Sie besonders vermissen,
jetzt, da Sie sie nicht sehen,
was ist es,
was Sie am meisten vermissen?
Die Nähe der Frau und alles.
Wir sind seit 65 Jahren verheiratet.
Was will man da machen,
wenn man plötzlich alleine ist?
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Spitexmitarbeiterin Anja Schneider.
Seit Ausbruch der Corona-Pandemie
hat sie viel zu tun,
denn oft bleiben Patienten
lieber zu Hause,
statt zum Arzt oder ins Krankenhaus
zu gehen.
Und weil auch Angehörige
zu Hause bleiben müssen,
sind die Spitexmitarbeiterinnen
vielfach die Einzigen,
die Betroffene besuchen.
Guten Morgen!
- Guten Morgen.
Ich kann ja meine Frau nicht mehr
besuchen. Nur noch telefonieren.
Rufen Sie sie jeden Tag an?
- Praktisch, ja.
Wir brauchen mehr Zeit
für unsere Einsätze,
weil wir
einerseits mehr Zeit brauchen
für die Umsetzung
der Schutzmassnahmen
und andererseits
sind wir ja häufig auch
die einzige direkte Kontaktperson,
die die Leute haben,
und sie schätzen
den Austausch mit uns sehr.
Machen wir noch den Verband?
Hoffentlich ist das bald mal vorbei,
ich habe ihn schon lange.
Ich hoffe es auch.
Für die Leute
ist diese fast totale Isolation
wirklich
eine grosse Herausforderung,
die auch psychisch
belastend sein kann.
Und wir wollen insbesondere jetzt
die Leute auch unterstützen.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Angst?
Was soll ich sagen, Angst?
Klar ist man nicht gleichgültig,
aber gleich partout Angst?
Was willst du tun? Entweder
kommt das Virus oder es kommt nicht.
Man kann nicht Angst haben
und dann ...
Denken Sie mehr an den Tod
in diesen Zeiten?
Hä?
Denken Sie mehr an den Tod
in diesen Zeiten?
Nein, gar nicht. Gar nicht.
Ich lebe noch zu gerne.
Ja, ja.
Ich darf jetzt zu Herrn Birrer,
der hier im Alterszentrum wohnt.
Ich kaufe
zum dritten Mal für ihn ein.
Immer am Freitag und am Dienstag.
Das ist schon Routine geworden.
Ich muss in meine Handschuhe kommen.
Hoi, Robert!
- Sali!
Wie geht's?
Danke, gut.
Ich fühle mich wohl hier.
Nussbrot, vier Semmel -
ein Schild, weisst du?
Und eine Linzer Torte,
aber eine grosse!
Ja, letztes Mal
habe ich die kleine gebracht.
Ich lege mir immer gleich einen
Ersatz zu von dem, was ich brauche.
Ich bin natürlich froh,
gewisse Dinge immer zu haben.
Ich habe es aufgeschrieben.
Hier noch die Cumulus-Karte.
Letztes Mal hast du sie vergessen!
Ja, das habe ich.
- Das wäre alles.
Ich finde es
einfach wahnsinnig toll.
Schön, dass die Jungen
so etwas machen für die Alten.
Und zwar sofort, nicht erst, wenn
man sie darauf aufmerksam macht.
Henrik Maag koordiniert
eine Gruppe junger Helfer.
Grüezi, Frau Imboden,
hier ist Henrik.* Türbuzzer *
Ich glaube, es ist ziemlich viel.
Aber es ist alles in einem Laden.
Ja, hallo, Hanna. Treffen wir uns in
der Migros? Ich bin in 5 Min. dort.
Ist gut? Bestens, bis gleich. Ciao!
Das ist unser Zettel. So bieten wir
unsere Dienstleistung an.
Nein, weiter!
Gleich daneben.
- Die hier?
Das sind Amandine-Kartoffeln, ja.
Mir fehlen noch zwei Dinge.
Hanna, die den Rest macht,
ist wohl auch bald fertig.
"Streuwürze Herbamare,
siehe Bildli." Hast du Bilder?
Ich habe Bilder, ja.
Und Joghurt M-Classic
habe ich auch nicht gefunden.
Zweimal haben sie uns
zu wenig Geld mitgegeben.
Dann haben wir es vorgeschossen,
und sie gaben es uns zurück.
Kannst du ... Du kennst die Adresse,
gell? Und sonst rufst du mich an.
Hey, wo seid ihr? Holt ihr
das Zeug schon? Super, ciao!
Es sind im Moment ca. 40,
die sich freiwillig melden.
U.a. die da,
die eben hineingegangen sind.
* Tragende Klänge *
Viele wollen uns
ein Trinkgeld geben.
Wir nehmen es grundsätzlich nicht
an und animieren die Leute dazu,
das Geld zu spenden.
Grüezi.
Ich habe Ihnen alles hingelegt.
Ähm ...
- Vielen Dank!
... vier, fünf Dinge waren
ausverkauft. U.a. WC-Papier.
Jetzt geht's gerade noch.
- Sonst melden Sie sich wieder!
Wir sind beide ...
- ... über 70.
Und meine F... Also Sabine
hat Asthma, da sollten wir ...
Wir können nicht mehr
einkaufen gehen, das ist klar.
Wir könnten schon, aber wir finden
es besser, es nicht zu machen.
Nein, wir können nicht.
Einmal pro Tag gehen wir raus.
Einfach immer mit 2-3 m Distanz,
wenn uns jemand entgegenkommt.
1-2 Std. spazieren wir jeden Tag.
Und wir turnen hier,
lernen Italienisch, spielen Klavier.
Am nächsten Freitag wieder.
Super. Melden Sie sich einfach!
Schönes Wochenende!
Adieu!
Das Video für das Beatmungsgerät,
das du gestern geschickt hast ...
Wie man es
aus den lustigen Arztserien kennt,
wo man drückt
und das Teil über den Mund hält.
Verwendet auch General Motors
diese Open Source,
um diese Beatmungsgeräte
herzustellen?
Adrian Steiner prüft eine neue Idee.
Morgen zusammen.
Alles gut?
- Ja, danke.
Wir haben letzten Sonntag
von Starbucks eine Anfrage bekommen,
ob wir bereit wären,
für sie nicht nur Kaffeemaschinen,
sondern auch Beatmungsgeräte
zu entwickeln und herzustellen.
Wie fändest du diese Idee?
Ich fände das super,
mal etwas anderes. Abwechslung.
Von der Technologie her
ist es kein grosser Unterschied.
Wir bauen, was Sie sagen.
Wie in aller Welt kommt
Starbucks darauf, euch zu fragen,
ob ihr für sie Beatmungsgeräte
produziert?
Ich habe den Eindruck,
dass das Vertrauen
in die amerikanische Industrie
nicht sehr gross ist.
- Das haben sie nicht gesagt.
Telefonisch schon,
aber nicht schriftlich.
Diese Komponenten werden
für Beatmungsgeräte eingesetzt.
Das haben wir vom Zulieferpartner
HyDrive diese Woche erfahren.
Sie sind da also
schon voll in den Abklärungen.
Sie haben das Gefühl,
das könnte klappen?
Als ewiger Optimist auf jeden Fall,
ja.
Dann würde ich gern zu Tom gehen.
... um euch vorzustellen,
dass wir am medizinischen Weg
hier nichts verändern,
sondern nur an diesem
mechanischen Teil etwas machen,
das es öffnet und schliesst.
Es ist dem, was wir im Labor
für die Komponententests machen,
sehr ähnlich.
Habt ihr Fragen
zu dieser mittel-verrückten Idee,
Beatmungsgeräte herzustellen?
Die kommen dann wohl noch.
Gut. Dann ist es so, dass uns
aus Italien einzelne Artikel,
namentlich Kühlschränke,
Ende nächster Woche ausgehen.
Das wirkt sich auch
auf die Mitarbeiter aus.
Wir haben immer mehr
entbehrliche Mitarbeiter.
Wir werden nicht darum herum kommen,
gewisse Leute punktuell zu Hause zu
lassen. Das wird auf uns zukommen.
Wie viele und wann,
werden wir sehen.
Jetzt gehen wir aber in eine
sehr ... Nein! Nein, nein, nein.
Wir haben hier als Unternehmen
auch eine Verantwortung.
Wir machen keine Kurzarbeit.
Wir haben genug Arbeit!
Das kann ich so nicht hinnehmen.
Ich möchte darüber
noch einmal diskutieren,
möchte,
dass wir nochmals kreativ werden.
Aber diese Option sehe ich nicht.
Ich will auch nicht, dass
im Unternehmen so kommuniziert wird.
Wir sind gefordert,
das ist uns allen klar.
Es ist nie einfach in einer Krise.
Aber wir schauen
zu unseren Mitarbeitern.
Okay, dann tun wir unser
Möglichstes, um das sicherzustellen.
Ja.
Dann ruft er Starbucks an:
Um es klar zu sagen: Es gibt immer
noch technische Herausforderungen.
Wir haben nicht das Wissen
der Medizinalindustrie.
Deshalb haben wir Roche
als Partner gewählt.
From Switzerland.
Im Scherz sagen wir immer:
Thermoplan ist wie eine Pharmafirma.
Ihr haltet euren Betrieb so sauber.
Es sollte also einfach sein,
das Zertifikat zu erhalten.
Okay, take care, thanks so much!
- Thank you so much!
Ich überlege mir schon oft ...
Gerade anhand dieses Beispiels:
Jetzt wird Thermoplan angefragt,
ein Beatmungsgerät herzustellen.
Das ist ja Irrsinn.
Wir machen unsere Kaffeemaschinen.
Aber wie kann sich
eine Weltwirtschaft dermassen
vom Grundbedürfnis,
Menschenleben zu retten, entfernen?
Da ergeben sich
ganz andere Sinnfragen.
Wir haben schon Fehler gemacht.
Also da wurden auf der Welt
Fehler gemacht.
Meinen Sie
die Globalisierung generell?
Hinterfragen Sie
auch Ihr Businessmodell?
Ihr seid ja auch international tätig.
Jetzt muss ich aufpassen,
was ich sage.
Ich bin ja der ewige Optimierer.
Man sieht immer
noch etwas Potenzial.
Was passierte bei der Finanzkrise
und der Frankenstärke?
Die Marge wurde immer kleiner.
Man will sie natürlich
wieder zurückholen,
und das macht man mit Effizienz -
dieses wunderschöne Wort.
Mit Optimierungen im ganzen Fluss.
Überall kann man noch etwas
optimieren, was wir auch machten,
und die Marge
kam auch wieder zurück.
Bereuen Sie das nun in der Krise?
- Es holt uns nun ein wenig ein.
Wir sind wohl zu weit gegangen,
sonst hätte unsere Produktion
nicht nächste Woche
keine Kühlschränke mehr,
wie ich es angetönt habe.
Da haben wir zu stark optimiert.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass wir
sehr viel aus dieser Krise lernen.
Ostersamstag: Daniel Koch
unterwegs zur Medienkonferenz.
Mit guten Nachrichten.
Im Moment sieht es gut aus,
die Zahlen gehen weiter zurück.
Wenn es so weitergeht, kommt es gut.
Aber es hängt davon ab,
wie sich die Bevölkerung weiter
an Massnahmen und Vorgaben hält.
Gehören Sie theoretisch nicht
auch zur Risikogruppe?- Nein.
Noch ein paar Monate zu jung?
- Noch ein paar Tage.
Ernsthaft: Ist das kein Gedanke, was
die Krankheit mit Ihnen machen würde,
wenn Sie sie bekämen?
- Nein.
Warum nicht?
Die Chance, dass ich nicht
schwer erkranke, ist relativ hoch.
Es geht ja nicht um das Datum.
Man geht ja nicht durchs Leben
und denkt: "Jetzt werde ich krank."
Man muss flexibel sein,
flexibel im Sinn,
dass wir nicht wissen, wie schnell
die Fallzahlen zurückgehen,
wie schnell
die Hospitalisationen zurückgehen.
Es kann sein, dass das Virus
jetzt bei schönem Wetter
viel schlechter übertragen wird,
dass dann weniger angesteckt werden.
Dann muss man sicher
die Massnahmen anpassen,
und da braucht es Flexibilität.
(Journalistin) Sind wir also
über den Berg der Kurve hinaus?
Ja, wenn der Berg, über den
wir sind, der letzte Berg war,
dann sind wir darüber hinaus.
Im Moment sieht die Sache gut aus,
muss man sagen.
Aber es ist sicher zu früh
jetzt zu sagen, alles sei vorbei.
Wir haben noch einen
ziemlich langen Weg zu gehen.
Das Personal braucht jetzt
unbedingt solche Erfolgserlebnisse,
denn wir haben Patienten,
die lange hier sind
und sehr schwere Verläufe haben.
Wenn man jemanden auf die Abteilung
oder die IMC verlegen kann,
ist das schön.
Wir wurden nicht so überschwemmt
wie das Welschland oder das Tessin.
Das Maximum war eine Belegung von 21
Patienten auf der Intensivstation.
Wir hoffen, dass es so weitergeht
und wir unsere Reservestation
nicht öffnen müssen.
Wir haben herausgefunden, dass das
Virus in den Gefässwänden sitzt,
in der innersten Schicht
der Gefässwände.
Das Virus befällt diese,
was schliesslich zu den
Mikrozirkulationsstörungen führt,
die wir in allen Organen haben.
Damit haben wir eigentlich erklärt,
warum das Virus in allen Organen
so starke Probleme verursacht.
Nun fragt sich noch,
wie man das therapieren kann.
* Abwartende Klänge *
Je näher wir zusammenfahren,
desto mehr Volumen
geben wir in den Patienten.
Jetzt sehen wir hier, dass sich
der Brustkorb dementsprechend anhebt
und die Luft
über den Beatmungsbeutel
in den Patienten gedrückt wird.
Ist das das,
was du dir vorgestellt hast?
Es ist faszinierend von der
Technik her, aber auch ungewohnt.
Wenn man hier ... Es ist eine Puppe,
aber man sieht die Luft, das Atmen.
Das ist emotional.
Ich bin ... beeindruckt.
Absolut.
Welche Teile an diesem Gerät
sind nun Kaffeemaschinenteile?
Sicher die ganzen Motoren,
die Spindelantriebe,
die Gleitringbuchsen.
Also die Zentralmutter,
aber auch die Gleitringbuchse.
Dann hier unten versteckt Sensoren.
Die unteren und diese hier.
Da ist wohl eine
Kaffeemaschinensteuerung drin? - Ja.
Das sehen wir hier unten.
Das Hirn der Kaffeemaschine.
Das Hirn der Kaffeemaschine,
Herr Steiner, kann auch beatmen?
Das Hirn der Kaffeemaschine
beatmet die Lunge, ja.
Hätten Sie das
vor zwei Wochen gedacht?
Nein, definitiv nicht.
Ihr habt wirklich super Gas gegeben.
Da noch ein Teil holen,
dort noch einen Nachteinsatz.
Das habt ihr wirklich
ganz, ganz toll gemacht.
Ich freue mich wirklich.
Sie sagten im letzten Call
mit Starbucks, Ihr Partner sei Roche.
Konnte Roche Ihnen garantieren,
dass es ein Zertifikat gibt,
dass man das auf dem
amerikanischen Markt verkaufen kann?
Garantieren nicht, aber sie zeigten
auf, dass, wenn wir es so machen,
die Chancen sehr gross sind,
es zertifizieren zu können.
Sie haben also grosse Hoffnung,
dass das für den US-Markt geht?
Ohne Hoffnung geht nichts.
Can you guys hear me?
- Yes, we can.
Yes, we can.
- Alright. Good morning.
Erinnerst du dich?
Du hast mich seinerzeit gefragt:
"Weshalb Thermoplan?"
Das ist genau der Grund,
weshalb wir euch angefragt haben.
Ihr seid unglaublich, wie ihr das
in so kurzer Zeit hingekriegt habt.
Vielen Dank.
Es hat Spass gemacht,
mit Teilen für Kaffeemaschinen
Beatmungsgeräte zu bauen.
Wir sind auch beeindruckt,
und es funktioniert.
Als Nächstes
bauen wir ein Spaceshuttle.
* Alle lachen. *
Amazing.
This is
some really cool work in two days.
Der Käufer könnten wir sein,
Starbucks,
wir könnten eine Anzahl kaufen
und sie spenden.
Wenn ihr eine Adresse habt,
können wir die Geräte
nächste Woche schicken.
Jetzt ist die viel schönere Phase
als vor drei Wochen,
als ich noch bibberte: "Hoffentlich
keine neuen Corona-Fälle."
"Und hoffentlich geht das Business
nicht ganz flöten."- Genau, genau.
"Hoffentlich schaffen wir das
mit den Komponenten,
hoffentlich
bleiben die Kunden bei der Stange,
hoffentlich, hoffentlich."
Ich bin selbstsicherer geworden.
Ich finde es gut, mal wieder
richtige Probleme zu haben. Also ...
Es relativiert einiges,
im Umgang, teambildend,
sodass wir fokussiert
in eine Richtung zusammenarbeiten.
Das finde ich noch schön.
Nicht die Krise,
aber den Effekt daraus,
dass es uns als Unternehmen
näher zusammenbringt.
Das finde ich eigentlich schön.
Ach ...
Ich habe falsch getippt,
das ist mein Problem: ungeschickt.
Im Grossen sieht man schon,
dass die Massnahmen gewirkt haben,
aber jetzt zu sagen, die Schul-
schliessungen hätten dies bewirkt,
die Geschäftsschliessungen jenes -
das ist nicht möglich.
Es wird auch im Nachhinein
schwierig sein, herauszufinden,
welche Massnahme
genau welche Wirkung hatte.
Was zweifelsohne
am meisten bewirkt hat,
ist, dass die Menschen
ihr Verhalten geändert haben,
die Distanz eingehalten haben.
Das hatte mit Sicherheit
den grössten Effekt.
Worauf freuen Sie sich am meisten,
wenn es vorbei ist, Herr Koch?
Eine schwierige Frage.
Ich freue mich dann am meisten,
d a s s  es vorbei ist.
Aber wie schnell und wann,
ist schwierig zu sagen.
Ich schaue doch schnell.
Heute können wir feststellen:
Diese Massnahmen wirken.
Die Ausbreitung des Coronavirus
wurde gebremst,
unsere Spitäler
sind zurzeit nicht überlastet.
Das ist eine gute Nachricht.
Nun können wir
erste Lockerungen vorsehen.
Die Lockerungen
erfolgen schrittweise, mit dem Ziel,
einen raschen Wiederanstieg
der Infektionen zu vermeiden.
Man kann bei dieser Epidemie
eigentlich
keine verlässlichen Prognosen
machen.
Heute wissen mir nicht einmal, ob,
wenn jemand
die Krankheit durchgemacht hat,
er mittel- oder längerfristig
geschützt ist
oder wieder krank werden kann.
Da sind einfach
noch zu viele Fragen offen,
als dass man sich
auf etwas festlegen sollte.
Liebe Thermoplanerinnen
und Thermoplaner:
Uns ist es ein Anliegen,
dass für euch klar ist,
wie man unsere Hygienemasken
richtig anzieht.
Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp:
Du trägst ja immer noch einen Bart.
Wirklich?
Sorgfältig über Mund und Nase.
Also von jedem je eines
und da auch je eines.
Noch kleine Schokoladen dran,
oder?
Wir halten schnell bei ihr.
Danke!
- Das wäre dein Persönliches.
Hallo zusammen!
- Vielen herzlichen Dank.
Ich hoffe, ihr kommt wieder ins
Restaurant, wenn es geöffnet ist.
Bleibt gesund!
Hallo zusammen. Kinder, ihr seht,
wir sind wieder im Schulhaus.
Darum machen wir heute
für euch ein Mathevideo.
Was willst du denn?
- Von vorne!
Zuerst kommt ja sowieso
das mit dem durch 1 teilen.
Gut. Warte kurz!
Was wir jetzt anschauen, sind
Zahlen, die durch 2 teilbar sind.
Einige sagten, sie würden uns
gerne zum Abendessen einladen,
wenn das alles vorbei sei.
Das sei
ihre Form einer Gegenleistung.
Das bleibt uns auch noch.
Adliker?
Hoi, Rosi!
Hoi, Eugen, hoi.
Wie geht's dir?
- Mir ist langweilig.
Langweilig?
Ja, mir auch.
Warten wir auf bessere Zeiten, oder?
Ich sehne mich auch danach,
wieder mal vorbeizukommen.
Wenn wir das noch erleben.
Ja, ich hoffe es, du.
Ich glaube es nicht mehr.
Du glaubst es nicht mehr?
Ja, es ist jetzt halt so.
Diese Krankheit, dieses Virus.
Man kann es nicht ändern.
Also, in dem Fall.
- Ja, in dem Fall.
(Unter Tränen) Ciao, Eugen.
- Ciao, Rosi, ciao.
Einen schönen Tag.
Ciao.
- Ciao.
Ja, ja, so geht es.
* Ausklingender Akkord,
Ticken der Wanduhr *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Meret Hachen, Lilian Zbinden
Philipp Schlatter - 2020